(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Чудово.
Тоді дивіться, стосовно проєктів.
Вас лишається лише цей і наступний тиждень на
розробку, тому що 23-го це вже буде
останній тиждень.
Тобто ви там робите вже презентацію проєктів.
Остання п'ятниця, це якраз буде через два
тижні.
У вас фактично сьогодні майже два тижні лишаються
по часу, які можна витратити ще.
Тому розраховуйте на те, щоб у вас вийшов
якийсь проєкт презентувати, тому що його треба буде
презентувати.
Знову ж таки, потрібно розуміти, що краще, якщо
у вас буде проєкт, з якимись частинами не
зроблений, але функціональними якимись іншими.
Тобто навіть якщо у вас 60% проєкту
буде зроблено, це буде все ж таки добре.
Тому орієнтуйтесь на це.
Навіть якщо ви не зможете його закінчити повністю,
ви можете його частково зробити і тоді вже
дороблювати якісь частини, якщо буде час.
Так, я бачу, у нас останнє зустріч на
9.30 це буде заняття, останнє 23-го.
Тому так, тут у нас буде ще в
цю п'ятницю тоді лабораторна на 9.30.
Стосовно цієї п'ятниці, я планував більше розповісти
про захист веб-додатків, тобто як зробити там,
щоб користувачі могли входити, генерування токену.
Те, що Сергій Олексійович частково пояснював на лекції,
я покажу більше, як це зробити практично.
І дивіться, можливо, так як у вас залишається
відносно багато часу, можливо є якісь побажання, що
б хотіли б бачити більше на лабораторних, тому
що в нас поки що зараз є час,
тому я міг би додати якісь додаткові цікаві
для вас конкретно теми з розробкою у лабораторних
заданнях.
Є якісь побажання?
Можна ми сьогодні позовічаємось, так сказати, і напишемо
у чат?
Добре, подумайте, в нас будуть ще два, я
думаю, що в п'ятницю захист додатків десь
пів заняття займе.
Тому подивіться, які їм побажання, якщо ні, то
я планував також додати, щоб можна було зробити
функціонал пагінації, коли в нас є сторінки, також
буде досить корисно для блогу, це також можна
було б подивитися.
А так, добре, тоді надішліть, можете в телеграмі,
в загальній групі, і там тоді поглянемо, які
проблемні теми є.
А так взагалі, окрім того, що часу немає,
чи все зрозуміло з тим, що потрібно робити
по проекту, чи можливо є якісь проблеми?
Поки є, у нас проблем поки немає, ми
знаємо, що нам потрібно робити.
Є анкету треба закріпити, щоб вона працювала, якісь
результати зберігала, якусь базу даних, і ще зробити
логін та паролі, щоб відвідувачі могли заходити, є
ще над чим працювати.
Добре, я думаю, що ви цілком це можете
зробити з тими прикладами, які ми розглядали на
лабораторних завданнях.
Я думаю, що не мало б бути проблем,
але, знову ж таки, якщо будуть, то ми
можемо їх завжди розглянути.
Добре, тоді загалом, якщо більше питань немає, я
тоді зупиню запис.